le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
l'agriculture est à la Réunion un
secteur porteur créateur de richesse et
d'emploi
les agriculteurs contribuent aussi à
aménager le territoire à façonner nos
beaux paysages
par ailleurs il produisent des produits
sains bon pour la santé mais qui sont
trop souvent encore concurrencés par des
importations à moindre coût alors
comment aider les agriculteurs à faire
connaître leurs produits comment faire
découvrir au citadins les richesses de
la production locale
on en parle maintenant dans le lien
social
le quartier du bas de la rivière à
Saint-Denis était autrefois un lieu à
vocation industrielle et agricole
il a activement participé au
développement du chef-lieu de la réunion
très actif ce quartier a été fortement
peuplé et très urbanisé mais les
fermetures successives des usines en
considérablement réduit la fréquentation
du quartier presque laissée à l'abandon
le Conseil général a souhaité redonner
vie au bas de la rivière et en faire un
écoquartier pilote expérience qui
pourrait ensuite être développée sur
d'autres communes
après des aménagements urbains et la
renaissance du collège redley il s'agit
maintenant de relancer une vie sociale
dans ce lieu chargé d'histoire
le Conseil général a donc cherché des
solutions pour permettre aux différentes
populations de se retrouver d'échanger
de partager
c'est de cette conviction que son nez
les marchés pays qui ont lieu tous les
deuxièmes mercredi du mois à l'espace
redley
l'objectif est d'apporter du soutien aux
agriculteurs réunionnais dont certains
exerçant à Saint-Denis en leur offrant
plus de points de vente et permettre aux
habitants du quartier de redécouvrir les
produits pays de qualité
Patrick est agriculteur depuis 25 ans il
connaît bien les difficultés que
rencontre le monde agricole en général
et trouve que le marché pays est une
belle idée qui lui apporte un soutien
financier mais aussi social
on pourrait écouler les produits très
très difficile mais le Marinella
au niveau contact avec les gens au
niveau de la vente même au niveau
financièrement pour le pour mon revenu
c'est un plus moi j'ai présenté le la
pataule
c'est un légume très très ancien les
gens ils découvrent des choses et aussi
ont découvert notre clientèle on a fait
connaissance on va discuter un petit peu
pour avoir on a donné nos idées aussi
un truc faut pas arrêter il faut pas
arrêter faut continuer
parce qu'il rapporte quand même quelque
chose avec quelqu'un aux artisans tu
sais qui vient ils viennent ici
c'était très très bon comme Patrick
beaucoup d'agriculteurs ont besoin de
soutien l'aspect financier n'est pas la
seule raison d'aider le monde agricole
ce sont des métiers très difficiles et
la reconnaissance n'est pas forcément au
rendez-vous grâce au marché pays les
agriculteurs présents sur les stands
peuvent partager l'amour de leur métier
avec les clients ils peuvent parler avec
passion de leurs produits au grand
bonheur des acheteurs c'est une équation
parfaite car le client y trouve non
seulement des produits frais mais à
meilleur prix car c'est une vente
directe entre l'agriculteur et le
consommateur les produits à la Réunion
sont bons de bonne qualité avec même des
produits bio et nous avons beaucoup
accompagné les agriculteurs qui ont fait
des efforts considérables à la Réunion
on mange bien on produit bien mais il
faut que le consommateur lui-même il
gagne et quand on met en place ces
marchés pays on évite les intermédiaires
du producteur au consommateurs c'est de
la progrès ce qui permet également
d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
familles réunionnaises tout en soutenant
la production locale et en soutenant le
bon manger créole avec les produits
frais le meilleur charisme couler c'est
le poulet pays donc voilà chaque
deuxième mercredi du mois venez à
l'espace réglé
autrefois surnommé le grenier de
Saint-Denis le quartier du bas de la
rivière est en train de renouer avec le
mieux vivre et qu'au quartier en cours
il revit grâce à des animations
économiques et sociales le marché pays
est un formidable moyen de relier les
gens entre eux les populations se
retrouvent échangent et partage elle
redécouvre des produits qui ont fait la
Réunion tout cela en aidant les
agriculteurs et en proposant des
produits à meilleur prix au
consommateurs le marché pays est un
exemple à suivre car il prouve que la
solidarité apportait des solutions à
tous les acteurs d'un même dispositif le
marché pays c'est tous les 2e mercredi
du mois à l'espace redley au bas de la
rivière
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais